Bienvenido de nuevo a la computación cuántica en la práctica. Este episodio se va a centrar en el primero y a menudo el más
desafiante paso para definir un programa cuántico: mapear un problema general a un circuit que pueda ejecutarse en una computadora cuántica.
Este paso describe cómo un usuario que parte de un problema computacional dado
puede traducirlo para que una computadora cuántica lo pueda entender.
En lecciones anteriores de esta serie, las lecciones dos y tres, discutimos que la etapa de mapeo es el primer paso de
cuatro en el framework de Qiskit patterns. De esas lecciones, quizás recuerdes que nuestro objetivo era traducir
o reescribir un problema computacional como una función de costo o un valor de expectación
que podemos evaluar usando una computadora cuántica.
En la lección tres, discutimos un ejemplo concreto con max cut, un problema
computacionalmente difícil y que es habitual en la optimización combinatoria.
En ese ejemplo, seguimos varios pasos para transformar el grafo inicial en un problema nativo cuántico. Nosotros
transformamos el problema de encontrar el número máximo de cortes en el grafo en una función de costo. Luego reescribimos esa función de costo
como un Hamiltoniano y preparamos un estado cuántico de prueba cuyo estado base
corresponde al max cut. Por último, construimos un quantum circuit que representa el estado cuántico de prueba de
interés y luego añadimos los gate específicos para permitir que el estado evolucione con el tiempo. Esta secuencia de pasos es lo que
llamamos mapeo. Y a alto nivel, el procedimiento es general para muchas otras aplicaciones, como la química cuántica
y la simulación cuántica. Ahora bien, no hay forma de eludir el hecho de que el mapeo puede ser difícil. No existe una
estrategia única para cada problema, así que puede resultar intimidante. Hoy voy a destacar
algunos ejemplos representativos de distintos problemas y describiré cómo se mapearon en cada caso. Haré un rápido
repaso de lo que aprendimos sobre los problemas de grafos como los usados en Max Cut y dedicaré el resto de la clase a
cómo mapear problemas que aparecen en la naturaleza, como problemas de estructura molecular en biología, electrónica
problemas de estructura en química y simulación de teorías cuánticas de campos en física de altas energías.
Pero antes de dedicar la mayor parte de este episodio a ver ejemplos de problemas de la literatura, quiero darte
una visión de alto nivel de las principales cosas que queremos lograr y considerar cuando mapeamos un problema. Hay
algunas cosas a tener en cuenta para cualquier tipo de problema computacional que deba traducirse a un quantum circuit.
Primero, puede que necesites simplificar el problema para hacerlo viable. Esto es algo habitual en la mayoría de las disciplinas científicas
y no es exclusivo de la computación cuántica. Si alguna vez has escuchado la expresión "asume una
vaca esférica", alude al hecho de que a menudo es difícil describir un sistema exactamente como aparece. Pero
en cambio, podemos hacer simplificaciones razonables que aún pueden llevar a soluciones útiles.
Algunos ejemplos de cómo podríamos hacer esto en la computación cuántica son limitar el tamaño o la profundidad del circuit eligiendo un
ansatz eficiente para el hardware, o truncar evoluciones temporales complejas, o ignorar
términos del Hamiltoniano que contribuyen poco a la energía final de un estado cuántico.
El siguiente punto que quiero destacar es que vas a tener que pensar en cómo escribir el problema de manera que una computadora cuántica pueda interpretarlo.
A menudo eso implica hacerse estas tres preguntas. Una, ¿qué representarán nuestros qubit
en este modelo? Dos, ¿es nuestro problema continuo? Como las computadoras cuánticas son digitales, vas a necesitar
encontrar la manera de discretizar el problema. Y tres, por último, ¿la topología del problema se alinea con la topología del
hardware? Si es así, perfecto. Pero si no, puede que necesitemos implementar algunos trucos para que funcione. Así que abordemos
esta primera pregunta. Lo que creo que está en el corazón de todas las dificultades para entender el mapeo, especialmente como
un concepto nuevo. ¿Qué puede representar un qubit?
Los qubit pueden usarse para representar muchas cosas. La primera y más sencilla, en mi opinión, es un nodo en un grafo. Los grafos se
usan para mostrar conectividad en muchos tipos distintos de problemas matemáticos. Y los nodos son un elemento fundamental que representa un punto
o entidad dentro de una red. Dependiendo de lo que represente toda la red, podría ser una ciudad, una persona o un
ferromagneto en una red cristalina. Los qubit también pueden usarse para representar bosones y fermiones. Aunque debo advertir aquí
que un solo qubit no equivale exactamente a un bosón o un fermión. Es un poco
más complicado que eso y lo explicaré enseguida, pero en general, una cadena de espines que sigue cierta estadística es
algo que puede traducirse fácilmente a una arquitectura de qubit.
Ahora nos adentramos en ejemplos que son un poco más complicados. Para estos modelos, ya no tiene sentido
hablar en términos de un solo qubit.
En cambio, necesitamos grupos de ellos para conformar algo físico. Por ejemplo, un
grupo de qubit aquí representados en una topología hexagonal pesada puede usarse para representar ubicaciones geométricas de aminoácidos
o cadenas de polímeros. Otro ejemplo es la simulación del scattering de hadrones
en modelos de física de altas energías, que puede hacerse simulando la evolución temporal de un paquete de ondas hadrónico. En este caso,
un registro de qubit puede usarse para codificar distintos estados de un campo cuántico. El estado vacío de ese campo o
un paquete de ondas que se propaga sobre este vacío.
También quiero señalar que mapear el problema a una computadora cuántica tiene pasos diferenciados: el primero es mapear los
estados a qubit y circuits, y el segundo es mapear la función de costo o la expectación
de los observables y operadores cuánticos. Veremos cómo se manejan estos en ejemplos específicos. Pero en
este punto hemos hablado de forma suficientemente abstracta sobre el desafío que tenemos ante nosotros.
Veamos ahora estos ejemplos en detalle.
Comencemos con nuestro primer ejemplo. En mi opinión, uno de los problemas de mapeo más sencillos es el que ya hemos
cubrimos con cierta profundidad el ejemplo de max cut. En ese problema, el mapeo fue bastante sencillo para nosotros porque un qubit
equivalía a un nodo en nuestro grafo. Usar nodos en un grafo es muy intuitivo y eso es
afortunado porque corresponde a muchas aplicaciones. Muchas veces cuando quieres modelar algo que corresponde a una
serie de nodos conectados entre sí, si los agrupamientos son binarios como cero o uno, o incluido y no incluido en un
conjunto, puedes mapear de forma simple y natural estos nodos a bits o qubits.
En este ejemplo, e incluso en el que escalamos a 100 qubits en el episodio 3, la conectividad del grafo
ya coincidía con la topología de nuestro hardware superconductor. Así que tampoco necesitamos preocuparnos por eso. Claro que no siempre es el caso.
Y si tienes un grafo más complicado o más conectado que los ejemplos que hemos destacado hasta ahora, vas a
necesitar implementar swap gates. Pero esto se maneja en el segundo paso de los patrones de Qiskit, que se ocupa
de la transpilación. La otra parte del problema de max cut que lo hace tan útil es que
ya sabemos cómo expresar la función de costo como un Hamiltoniano usando la formulación QUBO.
Recuerda que en la computación cuántica y los algoritmos cuánticos variacionales, una función de costo Hamiltoniana es una función
que codifica la solución óptima del problema en el estado base del Hamiltoniano.
Para construir el Hamiltoniano de costo, pudimos usar la clase sparse poly op en Qiskit para especificar la
conectividad de nuestro grafo y la etapa de mapeo a los operadores cuánticos queda lista. Y el quantum circuit fue
simplemente el QAOA ansatz. Si esto no te suena, por favor regresa y revisa el episodio 3, donde lo explicamos
con mucho más detalle. Ahora vamos a aumentar la dificultad un poco. A continuación, vamos a ver
un ejemplo modelado en el artículo llamado "resource efficient quantum algorithm for protein folding", escrito por
IBM en colaboración con la Universidad de Nueva Gales del Sur. Un poco de contexto bioquímico. Las proteínas son
macromoléculas compuestas de largas cadenas de aminoácidos. Estas largas cadenas se pliegan
en estructuras complejas que realizan una amplia variedad de funciones biológicas.
Determinar la estructura de una proteína en el espacio tridimensional y comprender las relaciones entre
la estructura y la función se encuentran entre los problemas más difíciles de la bioquímica hoy en día.
Las proteínas se pliegan en estructuras útiles debido a las interacciones entre los propios aminoácidos.
A medida que la estructura se tuerce y se pliega, aminoácidos que están lejos entre sí en la cadena pueden terminar justo al lado
del otro e interactuar con fuerza. Necesitamos obtener un Hamiltoniano que describa todas estas interacciones entre los aminoácidos
si queremos predecir qué estructura final minimizará la energía. Aquí nos centraremos en las cadenas de aminoácidos y
cómo pueden modelarse en una computadora cuántica, y luego cómo podemos obtener las distancias entre aminoácidos para
el cálculo de las energías de interacción.
Con esto, habremos reunido todas las contribuciones necesarias al Hamiltoniano para poder simularlo
en una computadora cuántica. En las proteínas reales, los aminoácidos pueden ocupar un continuo de posiciones posibles.
Sin embargo, vamos a usar una simplificación aquí y los restringiremos a un modelo de red donde cada aminoácido
ocupa un punto en una cuadrícula. Aquí, los autores usaron una red tetraédrica.
Una nota rápida: estamos codificando la dirección de las aristas y no los nodos en sí, como en el problema de max cut.
Cada qubit representa un posible camino de un solo paso a lo largo de la red tetraédrica. Observa que los sitios adyacentes han sido
etiquetados en este diagrama como A o B por sus diferentes orientaciones en la red.
La cadena proteica se representa como una serie de giros o direcciones en esta
red. Cada giro entre los aminoácidos puede ser en una de cuatro direcciones
correspondientes a las aristas del tetraedro.
Estos cuatro posibles giros se codifican usando cuatro qubits.
Esto suena un poco complicado. Así que veamos este ejemplo con un poco más de profundidad.
Coloquemos nuestro primer aminoácido en este punto de la red tetraédrica. La dirección hacia el primer
aminoácido desde el segundo es arbitraria porque el sistema siempre puede rotarse para que esa arista apunte
en cualquier dirección que queramos. Así que coloquemos nuestro segundo aminoácido aquí. No es tan
fácil de ver, pero el camino del segundo al tercero también es en realidad arbitrario. Las tres opciones
darían como resultado que dos de las aristas tengan un ángulo de aproximadamente 109,5°
entre ellas. Elegir esta segunda arista simplemente determina la orientación de nuestra proteína en el espacio. Así que sin pérdida de
generalidad, podemos elegir que los primeros giros sean simplemente 0 0 1 y 0 0 1
0. Con estas simplificaciones, la configuración de la cadena de aminoácidos queda dada simplemente por esta expresión.
Hasta ahora hemos mapeado las aristas del tetraedro a qubits y nuestro quantum circuit será un ansatz. Ahora necesitamos
considerar cómo codificar la energía del problema en un Hamiltoniano de modo que su estado base nos dé el
patrón de plegamiento óptimo. Ahora bien, para cualquier configuración dada habrá una energía asociada debida a las
interacciones entre los propios aminoácidos. Estas interacciones son más fuertes cuando los dos aminoácidos están
cerca el uno del otro. Obviamente, los aminoácidos que son adyacentes en la cadena principal siempre interactuarán entre sí.
Pero como la proteína puede retorcerse y plegarse, otros pares de aminoácidos
también pueden interactuar. Los aminoácidos 10 y 20, por ejemplo, podrían terminar en
sitios adyacentes después de que la proteína se haya plegado. Los aminoácidos que terminan cerca tienen interacciones
más fuertes e impulsan el proceso de plegamiento, pero no necesariamente tienen índices que estén cerca entre
sí. Así que necesitamos una fórmula para describir la distancia D entre los aminoácidos I y
J usando la información codificada en los qubits de configuración. De ese modo podemos
usar su distancia de separación para determinar con qué fuerza están interactuando. Esto es un poco complicado
pero ten paciencia porque es un truco ingenioso. Primero, introduzcamos una función f sub a de i que indica si
una arista a se usa o no para el giro en el aminoácido i. Aquí, a puede tomar cualquiera
de las cuatro direcciones posibles en función de la codificación de configuración anterior. Podemos escribir estas funciones y luego
podemos definir una diferencia en el número de giros etiquetados con a en las redes A y B, desde
el índice I hasta el índice J, como delta N. ¿Por qué haríamos esto? Bueno, resulta que
la red tetraédrica tiene una propiedad muy útil. Centrémonos en este aminoácido de aquí. No importa cuál
sea, pero llamémoslo el aminoácido E. Queremos saber qué tan separado estará el aminoácido j. Y todo lo que tenemos
son las aristas a lo largo de las cuales avanza la cadena principal. Partiendo de I, observa que un paso
desde el centro a lo largo de un tipo de arista particular —llamémoslo a— desde este sitio de red A
es exactamente opuesto y se deshace con un paso a lo largo de la arista a desde los
sitios b. Así, múltiples pasos a lo largo de la arista A desde cualquier sitio de red A alejan
la cadena principal del aminoácido E, y los pasos a lo largo del tipo de arista A desde los sitios B
te devuelven. Entonces, la distancia entre dos aminoácidos I y J a lo largo del tipo de arista
que etiquetaremos A depende de la diferencia entre los pasos dados a lo largo de A
desde sitios A y sitios B. Como A y B alternan necesariamente en la
cadena principal de la proteína, esto queda capturado por el término menos 1 elevado a K. Y este argumento también se aplica a otros tipos de aristas.
Así, la distancia entre aminoácidos en los pasos de la red tetraédrica puede calcularse al final mediante esta
expresión. Pero, ¿cómo obtenemos el Hamiltoniano a partir de esta larga ecuación para la distancia total entre los aminoácidos?
En realidad existe una correspondencia uno a uno entre estas distancias en los pasos de la red tetraédrica y la distancia
euclidiana. Y puedes ver que ya calculé algunas de las expresiones para ti.
Estas distancias se pueden usar para calcular la energía de tu configuración.
Dependiendo de tu propósito, podrías definir una distancia de corte por debajo de la cual consideres que el par está interactuando,
o podrías hacer algo más complicado. Puede que no sea evidente, pero en realidad ya terminamos con la etapa de
mapeo al hacer esto. Los estados de los qubits indican el giro, y el conjunto de giros dicta
la distancia entre cualquier par de aminoácidos. Los pares de diversas especies de aminoácidos
tienen interacciones distintas, algunas atractivas y otras repulsivas. Si usas la configuración y la distancia para
simplemente determinar si las interacciones entre aminoácidos conocidos están activas o inactivas,
sus intensidades son bien conocidas. No por mí, pero puedes consultarlas en una tabla como esta. Entonces, en resumen,
en este ejemplo los qubits se usan para marcar posiciones en una red que juntas forman una cadena de aminoácidos.
Y al simular cómo se doblan y pliegan, podemos encontrar mejores resultados en la investigación médica. Ahora,
omitimos cómo calcular algunos términos de este Hamiltoniano porque eran muy específicos de este problema, mientras que definir
direcciones en una red puede aplicarse de forma más general.
Ahora, una vez que tienes un Hamiltoniano general, siempre querrás traducirlo a operadores de Pauli, que son
nativos de la computadora cuántica. Eso es lo que discutiremos a continuación.
Sigamos. Ahora exploremos cómo traducir un sistema de partículas subatómicas a operadores de Pauli. Las partículas subatómicas
se dividen en dos categorías: bosones y fermiones. Los bosones
como los fotones o el bosón de Higgs obedecen cierto conjunto de reglas estadísticas, y los fermiones como los electrones o los neutrinos obedecen otro.
La diferencia clave entre ellos es que los bosones pueden ocupar el mismo estado. No hay límite para cuántos
bosones pueden estar en el estado base o en cualquier otro estado excitado. Los fermiones, en cambio, son egoístas. Exigen que
cada partícula tenga su propio estado cuántico. Los bosones también tienen espines enteros, mientras que los fermiones tienen espines semienteros,
como el electrón de espín 1/2 o partículas más exóticas de espín tres medios. Para
describir un sistema de partículas necesitamos una descripción de su energía. Centrémonos en los fermiones. Podemos empezar con el
Hamiltoniano escrito en términos de lo que llamamos operadores C. Estos son básicamente objetos matemáticos que
corresponden a crear o aniquilar un fermión en un estado del sistema.
Estos se escriben a menudo como fi daga y fi en una notación que llamamos segunda
cuantización. Fi daga es el operador que crea un fermión en el estado i. Fi es
el operador que destruye un fermión en el estado i. Pero recuerda que las computadoras cuánticas suelen operar en una base de qubit
con reglas específicas para representar sistemas fermiónicos. No trabajan de forma inherente en el lenguaje de
operadores fermiónicos. Para cerrar esta brecha, necesitamos mapear la notación de segunda cuantización a operadores de Pauli, que
corresponden naturalmente a quantum gates.
Existen varias transformaciones de este tipo para fermiones. Una elección común es la transformación de Jordan-Wigner.
Las codificaciones de Bravyi-Kitaev y de paridad son más recientes para codificaciones fermiónicas.
Las operaciones bosónicas, por otro lado, pueden transformarse usando la transformación de Holstein-Primakoff o mapeando directamente
los estados de Fock a una subbase de los modos bosónicos disponibles.
Y también existen otras opciones para los bosones. Además, se investigan activamente otras codificaciones. Pero por ahora,
nos vamos a centrar únicamente en la transformación de Jordan-Wigner.
Entonces, ¿por qué no asignar simplemente un qubit para representar cada electrón? Bueno, no podemos.
Los qubits son distinguibles y los electrones no lo son. Por ejemplo, podemos etiquetar e identificar fácilmente qubits individuales en
cualquier dispositivo, pero la indistinguibilidad de los electrones significa que no podemos etiquetarlos en absoluto. En realidad necesitamos etiquetar
en su lugar los operadores según los orbitales ocupados, como 1s, 2s y 2p,
en vez de electrones específicos. Por lo tanto, en realidad necesitamos etiquetar los operadores según los orbitales ocupados, como 1s
2s y 2p en lugar de etiquetar electrones específicos. Así que cada qubit juega
aproximadamente el papel de un orbital en la molécula, que puede estar ocupado o desocupado.
Pero cómo lo hacemos es en realidad un poco más complicado. Así que ahora introducimos algo llamado el mapeo Jordan-Wigner para llevar el control de
la antisimetría y asegurar que se obedezcan las estadísticas correctas del sistema fermiónico general. El mapeo
Jordan-Wigner es conceptualmente simple gracias a la correlación uno a uno entre los orbitales y los qubits. Hay
otros mapeos que logran un objetivo similar, incluyendo el mapeo par.
El cálculo de la paridad de un estado requiere considerar múltiples qubits. En el mapeo par y otros similares, la
interpretación de que un qubit corresponde a un orbital no se mantiene.
Ahora veamos juntos un ejemplo bastante sencillo para asegurarnos de que entendemos esta transformación.
Supongamos que queremos calcular la interacción de un solo qubit f dagger f. Empezamos insertando nuestras definiciones para los
operadores de creación y aniquilación. Luego podemos agrupar términos factorizando la matriz identidad i y el 1/4.
Como vemos, nos quedan términos que les resultarán familiares a quienes trabajan con relaciones de conmutación. Este término aquí entre
paréntesis no es más que i * el conmutador de x cero e y. Y no
olvides la identidad que sacamos afuera.
Recuerda que estas son simplemente matrices de Pauli. Por lo tanto, el conmutador es bien conocido. El conmutador de x e y en
ese orden es simple: es 2 i z. Asegúrate de no perder de vista los signos negativos y obtendrás esto como resultado final.
Al final, hemos reescrito exitosamente una expresión fermiónica en
términos de operadores de Pauli que nuestro ordenador cuántico podrá entender.
Veamos rápidamente cómo implementaríamos el mapeo Jordan-Wigner en Qiskit, porque aunque creo que es
importante entender cómo funcionan el mapeo y transformaciones similares y verlos desarrollados al menos una vez,
no querrías tener que hacer todo este trabajo manualmente cada vez.
Especialmente para sistemas de gran tamaño en particular, podemos aprovechar la función sparse Pauli op en Qiskit para
crear fácilmente las operaciones de Pauli asociadas a partir de un mapeo. Una implementación
no óptima usará bucles anidados y requiere unas 20 líneas de código.
Enlazaré el código aquí para que todos lo exploren. Pero a grandes rasgos, los pasos son los siguientes.
Uno: usar la función sparse Pauli ops from list para crear un operador identidad
correspondiente al tamaño del espacio de parámetros a mapear. Dos: siguiendo la definición de los operadores de creación
y aniquilación mostrados anteriormente, usar la función sparse Pauli ops from list para definir las operaciones de Pauli x, y y z.
Esto mapeará los operadores fermiónicos de creación y aniquilación a operadores de espín de qubit, codificando el número de ocupación fermiónico
en la base computacional de los qubits. Y tres: generar el
Hamiltoniano deseado en la base de Pauli aplicando los operadores anteriores a los orbitales de interés. Esto suele corresponder a
la creación de una matriz identidad que representa el núcleo, los orbitales no interactuantes, y luego aplicar los operadores de creación
y aniquilación al espacio activo con pesos que corresponden a las particularidades del problema en cuestión. Como
mencioné, esto es solo un resumen de alto nivel. El código no es demasiado complicado y ahora deberías
sentirte seguro/a para adaptarlo a otros problemas de interés.
Ahora que entendemos completamente el esquema del mapeo Jordan-Wigner, veámoslo en acción en una configuración más compleja.
Puede que recuerdes este artículo de un episodio anterior también sobre dinámica de hadrones. No voy a repasar el artículo en profundidad, pero por favor revisa
el episodio anterior si te lo perdiste y tienes curiosidad. En este ejemplo, el mapeo Jordan-Wigner se usa para
expresar el Hamiltoniano de sitios de red con L sitios para el modelo de Schwinger en ausencia de campo eléctrico. Aquí
es mucho más difícil identificar con precisión qué representa un qubit en este modelo, porque es solo el
conjunto de qubits en su totalidad el que da lugar a algo físico: en este contexto, un paquete de ondas. En cambio, puedes pensar aproximadamente
en los qubits como piezas discretizadas del espacio, donde L es el volumen de la red en el que cada elemento o
celda unitaria comprende dos qubits. Los operadores fermiónicos que vimos en la diapositiva anterior describen la amplitud de
la función de onda en un sitio particular.
Entonces nuestro Hamiltoniano contiene estos operadores fermiónicos de creación y aniquilación. Pero para implementar tal
Hamiltoniano en un ordenador cuántico, necesitaremos expresarlo en términos de operadores de espín, no de los operadores fermiónicos.
Así que usamos la transformación Jordan-Wigner. Después de aplicarla, nuestro nuevo
Hamiltoniano se convierte en esta ecuación en la parte inferior de la diapositiva, donde sigma más es el operador de Pauli X + I Y y sigma
menos es X - IY. Una vez que tenemos un Hamiltoniano escrito en este formato,
la parte difícil de la etapa de mapeo ha terminado y ahora puede escribirse fácilmente en un circuit con operadores de Pauli.
En resumen, hemos discutido cuatro ejemplos de cómo se han usado recientemente técnicas de mapeo específicas en el
campo de la computación cuántica. Empezando por la más sencilla y avanzando hasta aplicar la transformación Jordan-Wigner a
la dinámica de hadrones. Me doy cuenta de que esto es mucho. Este material fue muy técnico
y si no lo habías visto antes, puede resultar muy intimidante. La buena noticia es que te prometo que se vuelve más fácil y
familiar cuanto más tiempo dediques a practicar. Y ese es realmente el nombre del juego y por eso llamé a toda
la serie Quantum Computing in Practice.
Esto no es algo que cualquiera pueda simplemente tomar y empezar a usar desde el principio. Requiere algo de estudio,
rascarse la cabeza, y probablemente momentos de frustración. Pero te animo a todos a sentaros con la incomodidad y
explorar realmente las preguntas que surjan a medida que continúes, porque esta es la única forma de aprender de verdad. Gracias por
ver el video. Este ha sido el episodio 5 de Quantum Computing in Practice. La próxima vez vamos a explorar cómo simular
un Hamiltoniano desde cero. Nos vemos pronto.